vorrei girare a spagna sotto un ombrello
rosso
vorrei girare l'italia sotto l'ombrello
verde con una bacchettina sotto
l'ombrello azzurro
vorrei passare il mare giungere al
partenone sotto l'ombrello rosa cadente
di viole questa poesia esprime concetti
di bellezza leggerezza rapidità unite un
rimando quasi invisibile un respiro
appena accennato questo respiro è il
mediterraneo questo muoversi contro il
sole con il sole in faccia con gli
ombrelli colorati o viaggiare nel tempo
tornando all'origine del mediterraneo e
della nostra cultura
forse questo troviamo proprio la
meraviglia condivisibile della poesia
più livelli uno infantile quello del
colore e dello spirito grazioso della
rima filastrocca un archetipico e mitico
del soul e del suo muoversi intorno alla
terra e infine quello profondo della
ricerca delle radici culturali
genealogiche nel mediterraneo orlato di
viole
ma perché inizia la lettura di una
poesia deliziosa sul sole per parlare di
rivoluzione nell'ombra
la motivazione di quest'inizio è la sua
percepibilità cioè il fatto che senza
conoscenza senso studio lo studio è
possibile condividere in questo ma della
contemporaneità percettive temporale si
nascondono larche limiti e sino al
disegno lo sono l'origine ma anche ciò
che continua la gela è presente come
l'embrione continua ad agire nei tessuti
dell'organismo maturo e il bambino nella
vita psichica dell'adulto condividere
avere in comune con altri idee stati
d'animo e gioie dolori con partecipare
la condivisione della meraviglia e lo
strumento di conoscenza più proprio il
dialogo l'interazione significano
contemporaneità
ma non solo temporale gli accadimenti ma
anche contemporaneità fisica di cose e
di concetti che nel loro a cadere in
contrasto determino la meraviglia e lo
stupore della percezione la condivisione
della meraviglia mette in contatto il
sentire personale di ognuno di noi con
quello collettivo coloro che coincidono
troppo pienamente con la loro epoca
combaciando perfettamente connessi in
ogni punto non sono contemporanei perché
proprio per questo non riesco a vederla
essere contemporanei significa essere in
grado di percepire il buio del presente
ma percepire il buio come dimostrato
dalla neurofisiologia della visione non
è una semplice non visione una forma di
inerzia di passività il buio l'ombra
obbligano l'occhio dello sforzo dello
sguardo obbligo il passaggio dal
guardare al vedere
contemporaneità di luce e ombra
contemporaneità di materia e anima
contemporaneità di corpo e di essenza
invetriata la galassia esser di
shakespeare contemporaneità di opacità e
di brillantezza contemporaneità di
realtà e di mito contemporaneità di
arcaico e di futuro
contemporaneità di infantile e di
primitivo
contemporaneità di autobiografia e di
storia collettiva contemporaneità di
geologia e di libertà
la meraviglia condivisibile che trova la
propria essenza in queste forme di
interazione di dialogo inter e la
contemporaneità corrisponde all'idea di
bellezza che perseguiamo è che dobbiamo
perseguire quest idea di bellezza che
lascia come esseri connessione fra
sentire individuale sentire collettivo
comunitario si incontra con il
giuramento dell'architetto che
chiameremo il giuramento di pal ovvero
il dovere di esprimere la realtà e la
contemporaneità con tutti i suoi misteri
sui panici gli errori inganni le urla al
buio silenzio la bellezza inferni e
paradisi ombra e io faccia con l'ombra
più rovente parella fiamma eppure a
tanto indizio vidi molto ombre andando
pone a mente questa folla cagion che
diede inizio loro a parlare di me e
cominciarsi a dire colui non par corpo
fittizio la differenza fra il colpo vero
fisico di dante e i corpi fittizi non
veri film tus simulati sottili dei
penitenti e che loro lottano sempre con
stupore ammirazione e uno dei motivi
ricorrenti della commedia con il corpo
fisico cioè da vivo dante può ancora
fare quello che i morti non possono più
fare progredire e crescere
spiritualmente fittizio che è diverso da
ciò che appare senza corrispondenza con
la realtà
chi vorrebbe privarsi o diminuire di un
soffio l'ombra che trascorre nel brano
dove san pietro in sala i malati con
l'ombra dopo la vista al buio
dell'inferno ove privazioni di lume
pertanto anche d'ombra dante uscito alla
luce austra del monte del purgatorio si
fa ripetutamente riconoscere come corpo
vivo dall ombra che gli jet con lui non
par corpo fittizio da questa radice di
certezza esistenziale che non si sa bill
angoscia ma sbocca in un'azione perenne
procede il mondo rilevato da masaccio il
suo dramma ha portato da uomini decise a
risolverlo e rimane come una delle più
alte testimonianze dello spirito umano
nell'arte d'italia l'uomo e il mondo
sono fatti della stessa carne l'ombra e
la dichiarazione di corporeità di
presenza materica di esistenza in vita
di realtà
la luce mediterranea non preveda
strazioni la luce nei the real a prevede
ombre accecamenti i colori
disorientamenti spaesamenti nausea sogno
fantasia realtà il soffio cresce il buio
è rotta squarci e l'ombra che tubaldi
sulla fragile palizzata sarri già troppo
tardi
se vuoi essere te stessa dalla palma
tolfa il sorcio il balene sulla miccia
su lunghissimi cd del tuo sguardo
l'architettura e la macchina percettiva
del reale luigi ghirri parafrasando
giordano bruno scrisse le immagini sono
enigmi che si risolvono con il cuore poi
parafrasando ghiri diciamo che
l'architettura un enigma che si risolve
con il cuore
il reale è un enigma che si risolve con
il cuore e un visa vi è un dialogo
duello una battaglia un amore ombra
colore luci sono strumenti di
connessione di chi asma fra visibile e
invisibile appartenenza al corpo e
all'anima fra terreno e ultraterreno fra
reale e immaginario fra deserte bosco
fra radure bosco fra neve di metà maggio
e sabbia fra marita e simbolico fra
singolo e collettività
ombra colore luce curano l'umanità
perché ne sanciscono la collettiva e
contemporanee appartenenza al mondo
esprimono l'anima moglie la curano
l'uomo a un ombra come il mondo le case
gli alberi e la celebrazione dell'ombra
la sua cura
il calcolare i movimenti e le sue
scomparse e una dichiarazione di
appartenenza dell'uomo al mondo in
masaccio e quindi nel cuore profondo del
rinascimento queste compresenze sono
messe in forma proprio dall ombra che è
realistica e tecnica ma anche misterica
impalpabile questa interazione fra
fisicità materica ombra colore sguardi
volti e contenuto etico e la sintesi
artistica potente assoluta di masaccio e
del rinascimento la nostra rivoluzione
dell'ombra parte così dalle fondamenta
del rinascimento dalla sua lettera gina
logica di appartenenza centrata
sull'agire dell'uomo verso il futuro e
quindi non dalla metafora del corpo come
esattezza perfezione ed equilibrio ma dà
l'idea di corporeità e anime dell'arte
dell'architettura intesa come creazione
condivisibile elemento di connessione
fra sentire individuale sentire
collettivo fra storia e futuro e come
dovere della contemporaneità un sogno
non so né mi sono mai preoccupato di
capire cosa significano i sogni
quale influenza abbiano sulla realtà
anche perché li ho sempre considerati
parte integrante della realtà stessa
ed è per questo che mi ritengo un
sognatore di città possibili un deviante
della mente forse sarebbe detto in altri
tempi un sintomo di disadattamento
rispetto ai ritmi deson abili del
progresso e dello sviluppo della città
della civiltà metropolitana ma ora che
questo tipo di sviluppo sembra assumere
la velocità di accelerazione di una
caduta catastrofica piuttosto che la
crescita di un organismo vitale questo
fare propria e suggestioni del sogno può
diventare uno dei pochi appigli alla
speranza per riacquistare un rapporto
diverso non solo con il proprio passato
ma soprattutto con il proprio futuro
fatto sta che ho sognato la cosa più
elementare che possa sognare un uomo una
capanna in un bosco la capanna con la
bocca di lupo una povera capanna una
dimora provvisoria il cui aspetto
evocava l'infanzia gli accordi i ricordi
ancestrali gli odori gli umori del
muschio del pane appena cotto del
formaggio
ricordi forse di una realtà
irrecuperabile se non nel sogno tanto
vero che avvicinandomi alla capanna
invece di gran dirsi lei oliva sempre di
più un luogo talmente piccolo da
considerarsi in abitava a va ad un
tratto intravisto all'interno la radio
lancia una presenza angelica e nessun
luogo è povero di poco conto si è
avvitato da lancia allora da questo
sogno apparentemente regressivo mi è
parso di comprendere visivamente una
realtà elementare eppure ricca di
implicazioni che non sono i luoghi che
devono cambiare ma le persone che li
abitano
una verità che gioca aveva capito
benissimo tant'è vero che in molte delle
sue opere
gli spazi raffigurati solo angusti
rispetto all'azione che vi si svolge la
stessa alla dell'angelo che ho sognato
somiglia a quella che attraversa la
piccola finestra dell'adico
all'annunciazione uno spazio è sempre
povero quando è privo di capacità di
relazioni ed è sempre bello quando
generativo di incontri di possibilità
sinora esplora inesplorate e forse
questa la felicità dell'architetto amate
l'ombra amate l'architettura grazie